see if you can find out what happened
because i don't actually know what's the
story here with you no like wait i'm
running away from i think you were
kidding this morning she shows up living
on the set this morning yes
rachel it's the stupidest thing i went
to bed saturday night woke up
went going to the bathroom and it just
crumbled i don't even know what happened
but it's getting better and i'm not a
doctor i even gave it a feel too
nate you're an athlete what is this
right here
it's on my achilles yeah yeah oh girl
but i didn't do anything rachel you know
i'm not an athlete
but it's really it might be the
explanation actually
it's lightly there it's getting better
it's getting better in a couple days
i'll go the doctor if it's not okay okay
but this is a really new york glamorous
night so we're excited to be there this
had to come out even though you had a
bummer yes yes yes yes yes oh my gosh
that photo shoot you all did oh it is so
good i love your accent what accent i'm
from
i'm from the bronx really no
i was like hearing things yeah okay
you know what i like about that picture
is because i think it really captures
the essence of us the essence of the
show you really get along yeah
we have fun yeah release the tapes i
didn't stutter i didn't stutter no no we
actually do we actually do that's what
makes it so fun
i feel like you guys have just created
this magic that we haven't exactly seen
listen look at what's going on in the
news we everybody's thinking about
buffalo tony was there one of the first
people on the scene we were there live
on monday morning
ukraine i just this is what i like about
the news you got the highest of highs
and the lowest of lows and we get to
cover all of it and we are seeing so i'm
sorry tony we are seeing so much when it
comes to
the amber heard johnny depp trials i
mean it has just become that's
fascinating too yeah yeah what are you
making
very sad to me though
that trial i don't know how anybody wins
in that case i really don't i really
don't feel like we haven't really seen a
trial
with this much coverage since o.j
simpson
because no one's been quite crazy enough
to make it all uh televised johnny depp
fought for this remember i don't know
why but that's why we're all seeing it
and we'll be talking about it yet again
tomorrow along with everybody else in
america
and e.t as well
you guys have created some beautiful
magic on the show what is one interview
you're hoping to nab in the near future
i get this question every single time
and i've yet to come up with an answer
so you all answer and i'll see if i can
come up with something
i want to sit down with dave chappelle
and that was before he got tackled on
stage so
even now more than ever i want to hear
from comedians about
free speech
because i feel like
right now
they are the last standing individuals
that are willing to say what's on their
mind and they're being attacked
figuratively and literally
i still want eugene goodman that capitol
police officer
who saved the day on january 6. i met
him at the white house correspondents
dinner and i practically genuflected he
still said no but i really think that
he's got quite a story to tell i think
it says something that he still hasn't
spoken out about it but i would still
like to talk to him and i also want to
talk to darnell frazier whenever she's
ready she changed the game when it comes
to
the coverage how we view number one that
we got to see the terrible death of
george floyd and really sort of woke up
america if you will you know we've known
about this issue for a long time but for
a lot of people they were thinking does
that really happen
so those are the two that i would love
to talk to
i would like to talk to jamie dimon ceo
of jpmorgan chase because he's done more
than any other executive to
change the official mission of business
from being just about shareholders and
making those the very tippy top rich to
making everybody rich changing the
mission from shareholders to a broader
stakeholder perspective sounds small but
it's all about the wealth gap and it's
all about helping the people who make
these companies as opposed to only the
people who run them at the top tony i
think he would talk to you have you
asked dude it might happen for sunday
morning it might yeah yeah it might it
hasn't been confirmed but it might
happen yeah
and how are we going to send him that
tape oh yes
i'll make it happen how are you making
things happen with the toddler and the
baby right now and your sweet part is
here tonight boy it is hard but it's so
much good in one life i feel so grateful
it's just
ice cream scoop on top of ice cream
scoop that's how i see it
congratulations he likes ice cream
bring that up
a little chilly uh chili flake on it
chili flakes finally gail i got to ask
you
when are you and
she
missed social butterfly she said bye
rachel i've been talking to you long
enough
is there anyone she doesn't know she
knows everybody dale knows she will drop
you know who i talked to yesterday and
it would be the most famous person
that's the most casual thing i know i
get it when are you gonna hit the road
again when are you when are you and oh
going to go on another road trip me no
speaking english yes you do oh yes i'm
game she's definitely not she's
definitely not i mean well it's your
singing
game speaking of that you might hear
that soon we just talking about the real
question is when is gayle gonna try the
most uh recently made legal
botanical product in new york state oh
yeah yeah i've never done that okay
marijuana have you
not an interview about me this is you
well i think we know the answer to that
question
are you rachel that's quite the
hesitation
there's no stigma
there's no stigma
i just never have honestly you know i
got drunk in high school
and i was a youth christian leadership
leader on keg beard made me so sick when
i was in college you know how you'd sit
around in a circle and they'd pass a
marijuana cigarette around and it was
two people away from me and i got up
went into the bathroom came back out
went that stuff was good after they had
passed me i just i've just had no desire
for one it's it's much more than a
marijuana cigarette okay
there's a lot of ways to okay what do
you call it i'm saying there's there's
joints there's blood there's edibles
there's all kind of there's topics
there's there's cbd lotion you can put
on your ankle to help heal you right you
know what every time i say marijuana
cigarette oprah always goes will you
stop saying that nobody calls it that i
go what is the cheech and chong movie
dude
okay okay y'all get inside and have fun
[Music]